there she is
speaking of lovely miss thinking of
loving somebody lovey you share that
little piece of trivia with me that you
just shared Oh
people are happy now that's the can't
see is can you see us dr. Josh Roush who
would not [ __ ] quit just like the
Ducks of Anaheim that he [ __ ] worship
so much God knoweth why he will not
[ __ ] you know ducks quack and [ __ ]
what did they say in that movie ducks
but what is it like attack we're ducks
where we don't [ __ ] around or some [ __ ]
I don't think that's it pretty sure that
was it I think me Leo Estevez was like
we're ducks mil [ __ ] around little
pricks and that was most I believe that
was the tagline of that happened in any
event give it up for Josh Josh punish
doc put it down put it on TV I sound
like you know let's start this [ __ ]
properly before the Sun Goes Down and
[ __ ] cuz don't let the Sun go down
it's gonna be like onward man when the
Sun Goes Down Ralph's gonna disappear
and [ __ ] right now
it is Sunday night you know in the
Hollywood Hills man
literally so let's battle the [ __ ] on
I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
yes we're sitting in the wrong chairs
man but guess what we're not even
supposed to be outside was beer today in
a normal world we'd be sitting in a club
somewhere shoulder to shoulder with each
other looking at all the bodies rubbing
up on one another and going like boy I
hope there's never a pandemic but two
today and here we are and yet here we
are still bringing you Hollywood
babble-on why because we're scared of
not being relevant during this corona
quarantine I know I am [ __ ] I read a
hashtag on Twitter this morning said
like something like now [ __ ] you
Hollywood are now Hollywood Hollywood
just learned or something like that and
it was a series of like Hollywood hate
and [ __ ] one of them was like they just
realized how [ __ ] useless they are
and I'm like that person's right useless
utterly useless so we're trying to make
ourselves useful by doing this obviously
we've got the distance obviously we've
got the gloves we're in the Hollywood
Hills were on my my deck right here
that's Runyon Canyon behind us the sun's
going down can't walk Runyon Canyon no
more help for you it's a tweet read the
whole thing
did they instantly put up one of those
Denzel gifs where he's like who or he's
relieved yes but here we are ladies and
gentlemen is it responsible we've got
distance between us more or less and
distance between him and stuff like that
so we're here to bring you some funnies
and some Sunny's with the Hollywood
babble-on way man how you been sir I'm
okay the least we could do I think is
try to entertain people while they're
sitting at home sheltering in place as
they say it's a Sunday night I love
wearing these by the way isn't it fun
yeah I like to masturbate with him to
pretend that
Manhattan is jerking me off just look
down just look at the hands kind of
squint so just the hand you like oh the
most powerful man universe given the
most powerful handy I've ever gotten and
I'm doing well how are you holding up I
know you don't anymore
it's 2020 it's it's April 2020 and a
masturbating Ralph Garman stars are the
snapshots we see memories I've been good
man I've been you know quarantined and
[ __ ] like I'm feeling for you know
veggie grill no Runyon Canyon it's like
what's smith to himself it's uh you know
honestly I thought I'd be doing more
writing but like I do a lot of reading
like I wake up and I read the news I
keep reading the news and before I know
it it's like 2 3 o'clock or something
like that the story that is gripping my
imagination today is the tiger and the
Bronx Zoo diagnosed with coronavirus
apparently animals can get it that
scares me because like remember plan of
the Apes yeah sure remember and there's
the old one not the new one right right
so what was it
conch was a conquest to the planet yet
conquest of the Planet of the Apes we
started taking the Apes in as pets why
because the dogs all died and the cats
and the cats exactly where he [ __ ]
dogs died and it was a tragedy all I
cared about cats could [ __ ] burn on a
tire pyre for all I care dogs and cats
were killed by a germ that the
astronauts brought back from space
that's right we had no domestic pets
what if like suddenly the world's like
oh my god the animals can get it how
quickly do you think everyone's gonna
start turning on their pets yeah you got
a dachshund I do what's the name Reggie
how quickly would you Reggie if they
were like Reggie's got the rona like
this oh and how long many years have you
had 12 you don't want to hear that poor
Reggie know what's coming no man I mean
that's that's what like you know I know
that's like people like hey man
if we get to the point we're starting to
kill all the animals we're way more
[ __ ] than your feelings so yeah I try
to I'm all this week my new practice
this week is to stay away from the news
I'm gonna try to stay away from the news
for five days how can you just because
why not I'm gonna bury myself in my
writing I'm gonna burn myself at the
fake mall
we're twilight of the mall rats is
happening and so I'm not gonna read
about the news as long as I stay inside
what's the difference I'm gonna try to
let it work cuz when your head you know
is just like I just got off an ashram
yeah it sounds just like a Jared Leto
move I was meditating for a month what
happened were you five days you're gonna
be anymore I said when you put your head
up there's gonna be smoking rubble
everywhere
I haven't mean honestly like when I look
back at five days ago
it's like it's incremental crawls to
hell so it's like I might as well catch
up five days from now I don't need to
see the play-by-play not right now I'm
gonna try for a week look we got nothing
but time to try an experiment thing
that's true and so I'm gonna try that
all right I'm not saying I'm ignorant
I'm denying the news I know it's
happening I'm just gonna close my blinds
and I'm gonna be that little dog and
then the meme man who's just like don't
worry about like with fire all around
him and [ __ ] like that you're the guy
now who jumps ahead five episodes of the
show just watching previously on corona
and then you have to like catch up just
with bits and pieces of information you
won't know the whole plot I love that my
everytime at the end of a show I don't
like the previously but I I loved next
week oh yeah stay tuned when I watch it
my wife is always like why do you do
that cuz it spoils everything and I'm
like it gives me [ __ ] something to
look forward to
yeah and she's like what does that mean
and I'm like it's not a statement about
you I'm just saying like it's a [ __ ]
trailer I look forward to watched
homeland tonight people could be
watching homeland stead of this Thanks
hmm and they didn't have one at the end
of the episode it was so like in a
first-world way like what the what the
[ __ ] where's the preview for next week
and my wife looked at me like you do
realize what's happening outside in the
world right now
yeah the least you brought it's got a
point she does I like to do that even
when I'm binge-watching a show I'll stay
through the scenes the up Cummings even
though I'm going to watch that episode
in about 30 seconds no just watch it oh
it's fun man gives you a little taste
yeah I agree
so here we are folks you're gonna get to
see the Sun go down on us and whatnot
maybe you'll see us go down on each
other who knows no that's not social
distancing that's true only only reason
we won't be going down on each other
that's right is because social
distancing but other than that
that'd be a great way we're saving that
for when we really can't get jobs in
Hollywood
we haven't become cam boys that's our
Daffy Duck move like we can only do it
once what news
Ralph well I thought we'd do a few of
the old segments even though we don't
have an audience I thought we'd talk
about some stuff something tell is one
of those segments Tinseltown sadly it is
there's gonna be some there's gonna be
some some people this week there is do
we have we have a jingle for that
jiggle-jiggle bear you're lucky you're
on air I'll do the jingles I'm happy to
do them man what's our first Department
Tinseltown sniffs we're gonna lead with
that yes get it out of the way oh man
and now it's another you know that
sounds inappropriate right about now to
do the funny voice no it's not for
nothing but a pretty good job a very
good job all right see they would pat
you on the back but I can't tell
entertainer an entertainer so I'm like
did I do good I need to be that's give
me love
relevancy don't forget to work your solo
camera we can look right down the barrel
okay
yes Josh give me a single now give a
single tonight's news that well go to
the two-shot we need red light so I know
where my camera is yeah this seriously
though this Raj is like
red lights you saw through this [ __ ] off
the deck where's my tally this was sad
news and this it's close to home cabin
close I'm free isn't important this is
important
tragic news the young actor Logan
Williams who played young Barry Allen on
the flash cuts the two shot he needs me
on this this is crazy this is not covin
related there is no cause of death that
has been released from his family yet so
we don't know exactly what happened how
only 16 years old this was a beautiful
kid who played Barry Allen in the
episodes of the flash that like made me
cry yeah his performance was so good
I've you see me crying on online about
it he was so wonderful in that in the
show I never met him never worked with
them in the episodes we did he's only in
the first two seasons I think yeah man
oh man but like that his performance is
so good made me cry it eventually led to
me getting a job on the show because I
was like online weeping about the show
so young so [ __ ] tragic very Jed what
it is now they haven't but Grant Gustin
of course came forward and talked about
how Welch a pleasure not only he was as
an actor on the set but also his
professionalism and what a kind heart he
had and everyone in that family is
feeling it today our hearts go out for
sure yeah and then they win right there
in a corona virus related deaths Lee
Fierro has passed away and you may not
know her name but you certainly know her
work she is famous for her role as mrs.
kinter in Jaws she has that famous scene
with Roy Scheider of course we knew them
know my performance is so good you
didn't know I was performing that was
when she slaps burn she's like chief
Brody's like yes
you knew it was dangerous and still you
let those people go swimming so my boy
is dead yeah Lee was a talented actress
from Martha's Vineyard from she was
local from that community and she stayed
there for years later being a local
theater promoter and was a big force in
local theater there in Massachusetts for
many years and she just passed away to
today
how old ninety-one huge bucket of wind
yeah but that was a KO but that was a
coronavirus related debt yeah
sadly bummer man I mean talk about like
you know I didn't see any of our other
work other than that one scene but like
it stuck with you for life
oh don't matter like the part it's the
performance that scene grounds that film
in so many ways because it puts a face
on the tragedy that's happening and it
stops being a monster movie and it
becomes a movie about loss and death and
responsibility and that slap is like in
a movie full of like this woman got
eaten alive and this kid got pulled
under and eaten to that slap is one of
the most bracing aggressive moments in
that movie honestly one of the most
shocking moments in that movie are so
not expected and you all feel bad for
Brody cuz you're like his fault let go
slapped a mask the mayor but man what an
amazing scene and he needs some heed a
days we got to keep it open we got to
keep the economy going I think that's
what the mayor said it sounded different
in the movie so that's it she's a huge
bucket win 290 [ __ ] 181 not a bad not
a bad run overall huge great run still
with an incredibly memorable like
performance one time knocked out the
part yeah like you know what I'm saying
it wasn't like oh man she had a lifetime
to do it her one moment in the Sun was
shined so bright we still talked about
it today
that's what people are gonna say about
me when I go Ted Underhill in Jay and
Silent Bob reboot they're gonna keep
playing that clip over and over yes
they'll be like he was 91 when he died
after all that Jack Daniels
are you sure kills viruses then they'll
say then no so he was that boy they will
be missed
yeah that's it that's it no what about
the lead singer for fountains oh yeah
well I didn't know we were gonna go that
far back but Adam Schlesinger of course
a hugely talented not just the front man
for Fountains of Wayne from your home
state of Jersey of course like he was
from New York though oh really I think
he was if I remember correctly no I
thought pounds of Wayne is a store in
Wayne New Jersey and that's where the
Ben
got their name from but I from way I
understand I thought he was from New
York but I could be wrong
maybe he is from New Jersey regardless
hugely talented musician singer
songwriter
aside from Fountains of Wayne he was
also the songwriter on crazy
ex-girlfriend did a lot of work with
Rachel blooms show crazy ex-girlfriend
won awards right he was oscar-nominated
for that thing you do the song he wrote
for the time yes he wrote music for them
as well
so he wrote that opening song I'm a
vampire and recently he produced the
Monkees comeback album as well called
good times he did all the production on
that as well really yeah man I had no
idea that he was that spread out I'm 52
years old and incredibly young yes we're
incredibly yeah I'm incredibly talented
too oh my god
and this is also a virus yes so it's
happening people so stay the [ __ ] at
home and and don't touch anyone and
don't go anywhere until we get a handle
on this thing I guess is the message it
says the hip recruiter went out and well
I have to come to you and I figured
you're safe you don't go anywhere you
just sit in that office and smoke weed
all day a dress can you be I'm
considered essential liquor stores the
weed stores speaking of liquor alcohol
sales have gone through the roof did you
see this in the news I mean that makes
absolutely no just me alone I think me
alone I was able to double alcohol sales
recently but they said overall in the
United States in general alcohol sales
have gone up about 70% people are just
loading up on booze my brother sent me a
photo yesterday go by the photo mat and
pick up an employee Express delivered it
my brother texted me a picture yesterday
of my mother sitting in a lawn chair in
his backyard and his there there on it
my mom my brother sharehouse and they
are on a small body of water a little
lake water feature kind of Leakey thing
right
so my mom is sitting in this laid out
deck chair with two Seagram's wine
coolers and in her double fisting
Seagram's and my brother just writes
happy hour 73 74 was the picture from
1987 she was Bruce Willis was there and
he was singing the jingle with her is
like Seagram's go to I'm cooler because
of the outbreak I can't do my proper
Bruce Willis impression by touching my
face I know you're not supposed to look
up those commercials on YouTube kids
that's an accurate [ __ ] portrayal
that that existed yes are you drink you
don't look like you're drinking you look
like you're wasting away stand up I'd
never do this to ladies but stand up
lady
[ __ ] brag he has lost so much weight
he's so fit and [ __ ] trim man I mean
you're not whatever you're doing with
the booze what do you just pouring it
down the [ __ ] oh no the booze is
staid it's the food that's gone you got
rid of I've stopped to eat it just
drinking now he's smart you lose a lot
of weight them yeah and once you're
drunk you really don't care about being
hungry I found out this doesn't nothing
matters I smoked my hunger away yes you
did so wait a second so is that what you
do all day sit around drankin oh well no
I work on a show called the Ralph report
every day Monday through Friday and so
that takes up the better part of my day
and I've said this for a while I have
been training for this very situation
for about two years now because I work
out of my home and I work all day in my
home and I don't go anywhere which is
pretty much the same thing I'm doing now
so it's true and I haven't come off the
road after a long time touring Jay and
Silent Bob reboot now on Amazon Prime to
watch for free I'm content to stay in
the house I'm not one of these people is
like let me out of here and stuff I'm
fine to sit home especially the more I
read I'm like no I'm good
I just want to steal myself in let me
get some tape and seal every nook and
cranny of the house are you more or less
concerned to now than you were when this
first broke more MORE yeah I'm certainly
didn't minimalize it in the beginning
but like I was always like I just went
on tour and I didn't get sick and I
touched a bunch of people in blah blah
blah
but you know the more you read about
like people who pass it on and stuff
like I'm like oh my god like I could
have been that person and stuff now like
now we know more although every day
that's why I really want to skip five
days of news yeah I mean in a world
where it's like this is what life's can
be for the next month at least
I think I could skip five days of news
because every day it's this incremental
kind of push toward paranoia and hell
and I just I don't think that's good for
to be I mean I'm not saying it's not
good to be you know up to date but like
I'm pretty up to date like and I'm sure
my wife will tell me if something beyond
the pale happens but the more I spend
reading the news you know it's like
anything it's just and and I read Google
News every morning from top to bottom so
I've watched the news become nothing but
yeah covert story yeah in every
department it's just all kovat and the
more you sit there and ingest it the
more one could feel defeated the more
one could feel depressed scared paranoid
like I I haven't done it myself but I
understand people who are like I gotta
buy a gun like nobody knows what the
future is yeah so I I think it's it'd be
good to put that aside for five days and
just go make up stuff make pretend and
whatnot I found that the the disturbing
part for me is and I know these things
happen
retro actively but the more we seem to
be doing the more gloves we put on the
more masks we put on the more so we stay
away from each other the numbers keep
climbing it doesn't seem like it's
having an immediate effect on what's
happening and that's what makes me feel
insecure and rattled by the fact that I
don't know when that's going to turn
when is that when is that curve gonna
flatten as they keep referring to yeah
that's the concern our goal it said like
that San Francisco did very well and Los
Angeles is doing well at social
distancing and they're saying that the
curve is coming down but like every
story that I've read in the last two
days is like this next two weeks is is
the spike here yeah like now we're gonna
see well New York yeah and hopefully all
this spreading out and staying
and tampers tempers that a little bit
and that's what we're here for ladies
gentlemen make you feel scared
I'm let's talk about something superhero
II and not cook like Batman's Batmobile
clearly doing around the hills coming by
we didn't talk about the Batmobile by
the way because you were on tour I think
when those pictures broke how cool does
that look the new Batmobile and the
bat-cycle yes I'm all for it I am too it
looked like like I've seen drawing
online that somebody did have like
Batman if they did it in the 50s and the
car kind of look like that and stuff
it's very cool I have no objections to
anything I've seen from the Batman so
far me too very cool and everything I
keep hearing is it sounds like it's the
long Halloween yeah that's when I hear
two Ant Man three just got its writer
they just signed a writer to work on the
script for that Peyton Reed do you know
Peyton at all Peyton's not the writer
who's the director I know I don't know
I'm you know I'm right yeah I know
Peyton a little bit and he is such a
great guy he'll be back to direct but
the writer is Jeff lovingness from Rick
and Morty lovingness love-in is a great
name lovingness
you loving it I'm loving us Jeff loving
us is that Patti that had to ease a
writer that had to have happened to him
like that must be the oldest joke in his
life yeah you loving it I'm loving this
I'm loving it I'm loving us
yeah I've saw that he's gonna write a
Man 3 yes but I also read that Paul Rudd
had done a draft of Batman 3 oh really
yes and the villain and his draft
reportedly was MODOK Wow yes
and then I've read that and again these
are all things just read online so you
know tomorrow who's gonna say Kevin
Smith says the villain in a Man 3 is
MODOK I believe I read an article that
said the information I just conveyed
came from 4chan so take that as you will
but they also said that they're setting
up the Young Avengers in ant-man
hmm because of Scott Lang's daughter is
now older because my game so she's
passed yet Cassie is old enough to be
was it stature it's her character and
then hawkeye's daughter you know was
coming out of series right and yes and
she's also gonna would she be older no
she went away with the snap so but still
so they're setting up what could be
Young Avengers so you know the [ __ ]
kid versions across the board right
which is exciting
yes yeah that's a Marvel movies
announced a bunch of delays well yeah
everything's pushed back they what is a
Black Widow it's not gonna be November
November and then the Eternals is gonna
be February from what I heard
yes and then the year after 2022 it's
gonna be back-to-back Kat Marvel - black
panther - so they've got another Thor in
the mix there - yeah yeah that's I think
the end of 2022 or something like that
so yeah they were very kind to be like
this something to look forward to but I
guess they had to because they were
moving dates and stuff so many people
were like but Black Widow on Disney Plus
and they're like yeah right daddy's
gotta eat yeah the like are you kidding
me
but they did they are chucking Artemis
Fowl on to Disney so that I think that's
a smart move like right now in the world
we live in
let's say they lifted this and they're
like alright go back to your normal
lives and [ __ ] it would take a Marvel
event movie to pack the theaters yeah
well anyone feel comfortable sitting in
a group of people like that for a while
and like if they do if they're like I'll
chance it it's gonna be for like oh I
love them Marvel movies I can't imagine
people are like I'll risk life and limb
for Artemis [ __ ] foul and so and then
they got a then they got to figure out
the you know it takes millions of
dollars to sell that movie for 30-40
million dollars to open that movie and
stuff and they'll spent and who knows
what they spent making it Plus what
they'd spend marketing it like you're
easily looking at over a hundred million
dollars that right now in this
atmosphere and this climate will with
movie theaters close but even if they
had open them up I
imagine like onward didn't do that well
right and that's Pixar so I think it
seems like a good decision man where
they could just kind of write it off and
be like look it's a lost leader for for
Disney plus it shows the audience that
like we're hitting them with like
quality it's not just mandalorian
brand-new series now here's a brand new
movie that was gonna skip the theaters
and stuff like mm-hmm for that movie I
think it makes sense for Artemis Fowl if
it's true if it's going to Disney Plus
that makes sense it makes sense to hold
on to Black Widow like you know they're
working on Marvel shows for Disney Plus
yes they're not you know the moment they
start going like yeah then then you
don't that's like you know you hold the
audience in your hand listen to me as if
I've ever done that you hold the
audience in your hand as Thomas I'll
paraphrase Thomas Moore like you're
holding you know a handful of water if
you open your fingers just a little bit
you can't hope to get that back again so
I think it's smart for them to like be
like now Black Widow is a cinematic
event and we'll wait even if it takes
two [ __ ] years we'll wait because
they got to keep those as movies and
that audience will always be there for
them it's like stuck the Star Wars
franchise you can go years in between
those event movies and people sometimes
will show up more because they've been
deprived so you're not gonna lose that
crowd if you hold on to that stuff greed
absolutely agreed so yeah it's I think
it's smart that they're that they're
crying foul and they're gonna put it on
thank you thank you yeah it's cold as
balls out here yeah it's even though
we're in California well the Sun has
gone down but it gets chilly in the
Hollywood Hills that's why I'm wearing I
went old school I know I'm worn of
Jersey in a long-ass time the ghost of
Babel past this is the extra-large
Jersey that I wore in the movie James
Samba and that's a smaller size than a
door backwards to wear three XL so yes
I'm still kind of swimming in stuff but
it's the warm the only warm garment I
had I my hoodie is in the wash because I
won't walk in today this is the second
coldest I've ever been working with
Kevin Smith first one I don't know if
you remember how cold it was on the set
of tusks in North Carolina
right it was boy we were shooting in I
don't know that that building that had
no heat and it was brutally cold during
that [ __ ] it was I just member huddling
up with Haley Joel Osment and Jenny and
we were just all huddled side by side
trying to get body warmth it was and we
were indoors I know like we were outside
but it was it was cold now this is so
strange that you couldn't see your
breath like how should have given that
temperature yes yeah this is this is
warmer than that but it's colder the
idea of doing it out here was like oh
they'll see the sunset behind us and
then Josh is like you got any lights and
I'm like oh [ __ ] I guess we know when
the show's over and they can't see us
anymore God turns out the lights the
show's over
placidway this is better because we're
in the fresh air we're not around
surfaces and stuff so it's just more
conscientious lovey and [ __ ] we're not
wearing masks but that's why I keep
trying to direct it that way instead
yeah Josh how's the what people saying I
like that fair enough Josh reports that
you're reporting things are going
smoothly what else we got Ralph you want
to a little Bieber news should we do
some Justin Bieber Justin Bieber nobody
[ __ ] needs you wanna know why I'll
tell you why cuz you're a little
contrary that's right name so it's not
all bad news when it comes to
coronavirus justin bieber has announced
he is canceling the rest of his tour he
is no longer going to be on the road
because of the coronavirus crisis I mean
where where was he gonna be on the road
well he had forty five dates apparently
stadium and Arena dates that were
supposed to kick off and they were going
to push it back and delay that tour oh
now he's gonna shitcan it yeah probably
smart so we have all died that bullet at
least we don't have we have to know
enough to live through that disaster
when will I get my refund on my tickets
Ralph because I bought Sky box seats did
you I didn't realize oh yeah I was like
I want you to bring in Wang's and
[ __ ] booze because I'm gonna get my
Bieber on in a booth in a box well I'm
sure if you've talked to your
your ticket broker you could probably
get a refund I'm like this with the
people of the Staples Center man they
know I love the Biebs
I'm a believer well those people get
their money back to pre bought tickets
that's an excellent question now some
places like South by Southwest was like
sorry actually it's a same defense hold
onto your tickets and then someday when
they reschedule all those dates you can
cash them in okay I'm keeping your money
and we'll deal with the tickets some
point later I'm sure I'll perform again
someday yeah you know you know how easy
it's gonna be to use those old tickets
for the new event piece of cake I'm sure
it'll be flawless
absolutely wow man yeah well look there
but for the grace of God go I I just got
off the road I don't know if you know
this I don't know if I mentioned it yet
what I'm doing Jane South Bob Reba wrote
it to her and had that you know had the
coronavirus like killed that that would
have financially like hurt us in a bad
way and stuff so I got lucky like in as
much as we just missed that one you
could have put that movie on Smith plus
your new streaming service my brand new
streaming service man it's good only
costs two three dollars a month you go
to youtube / youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith pay me three dollars and just
watch whatever you want right there what
a deal
what else you got that's it for news
really yeah that's just coronavirus
coronavirus coronavirus and i didn't
want to just you know it's funny cuz i
do a daily show with the ralph report
and I try to talk about something else
yeah and yet still you find yourself
circling back that whether it's concert
news or movie news or television news it
all somehow revolves around what
Hollywood is doing in respect to the
response to the coronavirus you watching
anything you know what I am watching is
the good place Oh finally yes I never
saw an episode of that when it was late
and [ __ ] catch up bro well and I heard
it was great I've never seen it I've not
I was like that was like I heard people
say it was good I was like just
fantastic so I said I got nothing but
time Netflix had it and I said I'll
start and I'll do
see and it's amazing I love that damn
show Ted Danson's a goddamn national
treasure I'll be honest with you I
watched the Endura
what's the answer my sub tweeted from
somebody I was like that was one of the
most beautiful [ __ ] pigs I ever saw
so I was like I'm gonna watch it and it
was beautiful I can't touch my ears it
was awesome
so it did make me go and also did they
do a thing where you hear the the the
screen direction the screen direction
yeah like the scene I watched you could
hear somebody going like he looks out at
the sea and he turns to her and somebody
is if somebody was reading the screen
direction of script well it must tie
into it because I was like that's the
show not but now I know it's the end I
know that's gonna happen I've been
[ __ ] spoiling I think it's just a
device they use but I made me go like
that's cool somebody should do that all
the time like I wonder if maybe they
started in season what are you up to I'm
in the beginning of season 2 now maybe
they started in season 3 my god anyway
so I've been watching that a ton of
course Tiger king I keep reintroducing
that to people like my wife soon-to-be
ex hasn't seen it yet so I sat her down
and I rewatched it with her and then I
was remotely watching it with a friend
of mine so I've seen it like three times
never mind you of like high school or or
grade school when you could be like
here's Monty Python and the Holy Grail
you got to watch this yes like but this
is a world where it's like you try to
pass on Tiger King and like [ __ ]
heard of it yeah everyone's talking
about it dummy yeah the like [ __ ]
laughing code up [ __ ] like
Welcome Party but it's good right it the
other day where I'm like look I ain't
trying to put anybody off their art any
artists do it by all means but it's
gonna be really [ __ ] hard to cast
that it'll shoot a fictional version of
it that is as compelling and fascinating
as the real thing because all those
people are like living cartoon character
can't have it looks like it took place
in Springfield yes I don't care who you
cast in I care who writes or directs it
it will be a
homage to that show blood like watching
a cover bay like this is a bandeau
covered version of a song yes but it is
so beyond compelling I heard that
they're putting up a new episode that
news flows came about from Jeff Lowe who
was doing a cameo video for one of the
LA Dodgers and in his message to him he
mentioned oh if you like the show we're
gonna have another episode next week
we're shooting it tomorrow or whatever
so I'm guessing it's going to be sort of
a where are they now
catch up kind of thing gasps I know
Netflix put up a tweet with some footage
of Joe exotic talking to them from jail
so that must be where it's gonna be
I'm guessing um so look for that if
you've been watching Tiger King what
else you've been watching a lot of
movies just like old movies - I like
company I'm like hungry for comfort food
so I broke out Butch Cassidy the
Sundance Kid the other day and I just
some of my old favorite films that make
me feel of a time where I wasn't scared
for my life so I watched the freshman
another great Rando and and Matthew
Broderick Bruno Kirby Bruno Kirby who's
amazing in movie and Penny and Miller
who for like a good block of time was in
every [ __ ] movie yes I just watched
the shadow of the other day she's in
that yeah of course she's wonderful
she's really good she's in Carlito's Way
but she's really great in in that flick
I forgot she was it she plays carmine
Sabatini's daughter yeah that was a real
fun watch particularly because there's
Brando essentially doing the Godfather
again yep like an updated version of The
Godfather
directed by don't want to see Dave nope
Andrew Bergman oh that's right who
directed in-laws
no no Who am I thinking of don't know
but Andrew Bergman directed amongst
other things
scent of a woman no way Midnight Run no
you're thinking of Marty Bregman my bad
see me like know did you see me
directors flame to Ralph the wrong
director which one's Andy bird you're
right that's no really who directed
Julie oh I don't know that I don't know
the answer was the same guy that
directed midnight
Martin breasts is it breast maybe I'm
thinking of Martin breast so who is it
Josh [ __ ] Sandra Bergman he was a writer
who weren't you soap dish as well I
don't know if he I don't know how many
films he directed he was a screenwriter
for a long time and worked alongside
with Woody Allen a ton no you're
thinking of Marshall Brickman boy we're
way the [ __ ] welcome Hollywood babble-on
we're in Hollywood [ __ ] we're talking
about this is like who's on first
I'm telling you Andrew Bergman who did
the freshman I was confusing him with
Marty breasts I think you're right but
he direct I think he directed soap dish
as well dr. Josh Roush was working on it
right now seriously
googling striptease with Demi Moore
interesting yes that's right my own in
Vegas
oh is that Copiah or Kapaa in the cage
thank you what else he do the freshmen
he did a rewrite outs okay there you go
but I did confuse them with Marty
breasts entirely who you confused with
Marty Friedman we're the worst rusty
that's why you come to us for your
entertainment news right those are the
guys that proximate who's [ __ ]
directed what - Marty I just put a bad
[ __ ] - on something today where I was
like fan first filmmaker second I can't
even [ __ ] claim that where I'm like I
love this guy [ __ ] I was completely
wrong yeah that's not good yeah it's not
a good friend
anyway the freshman was a fun [ __ ]
why yes I rewatched the last regim on
high holds up really unbelievably well
his Spicoli performance mr. Han
everything really holds up like there's
the first time sec
scene with her in the dugout and [ __ ] I
was never a teenage girl but like felt
authentic even at this age all of it and
then I watched this documentary series
that I was interviewed for about cult
films it's three parts like two hours
each part and one of them is like like
late night [ __ ] movies like
Eraserhead
classic comedies like Fast Times that
and clerks is one of them and then there
was another category like horror films
and stuff so as I watched the doc and
it's great and they talked to a lot of
people I was interviewed but they talked
to Amy Heckerling who directed Fast
Times right and she talked about Sean
Penn and she's like I owe my entire
career to that kid like once I cast him
that was it that I was and you remember
like in my mind Fast Times at Ridgemont
High was [ __ ] huge
I felt the same way apparently it was
not really apparently the studio did had
no confidence in it and they released it
out here in Los Angeles on like a couple
screens regionally like because they
thought it would never play across the
country and so it played here for a bit
and then it opened but there was no
support for it and so all that like oh
my god Fast Times came from home video
watching it on cable and [ __ ] not from
the theatrical run in my mind so my
memory of singing in the theater was
false no you probably did but it wasn't
like oh it was packed it wasn't Animal
House like Animal House was 100 million
dollar grosser apparently Fast Times was
not and I was so surprised to hear that
so it made me want to go back and watch
the movie and uh it just [ __ ] works
man a classic is a classic and it's been
a long time since I revisited it and it
was pretty compelling Cameron Crowe yeah
early camera crowd yeah when he was
[ __ ] I'm a kid in high school and he's
in his 20s genius what else have I've
watched you know I watched this week
before you get to you go have you ever
seen a movie called the idolmaker yes
years ago when I was a child I when we
first got story cable with Ray Sharkey
and Tova fell should the the
thinly-veiled story of the guy from
Philadelphia who found Frankie Avalon
and Faye B and all those teen idols from
the 50s yes Irie
watch that this past week and boy does
that hold up to that's enormous ly fun
film you're digging deep yeah it's
comfort food stuff for me it's just old
school I saw the first to animatics for
our Netflix Masters of the Universe
series animatic is the raw you know
animation black and white this is what
it look like and in its rawest form but
it has the actual audio from the actors
and actresses it has like a temp score
it has temp sound effects and stuff like
that it is tremendous man they did such
a great job there's a gigantic [ __ ] off
battle in episode 1 and it it's it is if
if you're a masters the universe fan
right now you're thinking ooh this is my
version of a dream [ __ ] off battle and
out on Eternia it is that plus more like
these kids knocked it out the [ __ ]
park
I wrote that script so I know what I
wrote and I was like all right this'll
do they [ __ ] took it and elevated it
the battle sequence looks [ __ ]
astounding and it's got every character
oh it's so good so episodes 1 & 2 the
animatics look fantastic man next
animatic I think I'm seeing another
draft of animatic number 2 and then 3
will come in soon man but like you know
it shows a year away right don't it
won't be done or out until probably
early 2021 right but it's gonna be worth
it man like I almost want to back the
[ __ ] away from the project right now so
as to not [ __ ] it up you know what I'm
saying like it's so [ __ ] like it's in
the hands of towns and people but I've
been watching the animatics and writing
additional dialogue sometimes once you
get into like the fight and stuff like
that like we were right about the fight
but we wouldn't write dialogue in the
middle of the fight like haha I got you
now Skeletor [ __ ] like that right so as
you watch it you're like oh you could
definitely put in some dialogue like
over this person's shoulder and stuff
like that just to keep the chatter alive
throughout it but the powerhouse kids
have done [ __ ] amazing man like it I
I'm telling you I'm delighted it's one
of the things where I was like I wasn't
expecting it and I was like I checked my
email and I rarely check email and they
were like here's automatics and I've
been looking at them along the way but
then I checked out of them and
stuff because I was like I'm not an
animation person I can't give notes on
this I check back in and it's fantastic
I'm so [ __ ] thrilled I wish I could
like [ __ ] it it was so good I instantly
just wanted to be like I'm gonna tweet
this but I'd be fired yes sued instantly
but it's so [ __ ] I can't wait to
share it does that whet your appetite to
do more animation the process it's um no
cuz it makes me go like I'm the other
guy where I'm like that went so well
let's never do that again you know what
I'm sayin like you only have one kid
it's not from lack of trying but at the
same time we were always like this one
worked out so well like alright let's
aim thing here where I'm like man this
was fantastic like navona hedged my bets
cuz what if I'm like it'll always be
like that and then I go do it with
somebody else and it's not that at all
and stuff I mean it wasn't the
experience unfortunately with Howard the
Duck yeah like you know but to be fair I
wasn't like knee-deep in Howard the Duck
that was Dave and the crew of writers my
heart goes out to them but what about
with your own IP though I mean after
having done clerks animated would you do
that with other characters or other
worlds would you do a animated Mallrats
would you do and would you do further
adventures of the brats ease those those
characters especially at Yoga hoses for
example totally he was a cartoon you
know live-action one absolutely totally
I mean maybe that's maybe that's what
should happen to yoga Netflix would be
like a man didn't work once I'm like I
know but never say die it's a good idea
you can be a producer well one of these
days some podcaster - producer yes the
Ralph report ladies and gentlemen give
them their dress just go to the Ralph's
report.com and get all the information
but it's on patreon.com so if you go if
you're already on patreon if you go
patreon.com slash the Ralph's report
Monday through Friday we give you an
hours of a morning show each and every
day
in my vice House mr. Eddie pan source
it's a along with other guests and
craziness and good times so all are
welcome and on 420 Focus Features asked
me to host Mallrats viewing party oh how
awesome online yeah so there'll be
details about it somewhere but I'll be
sitting there answering your questions
and stuff like that mark your calendars
for twenty a day to get stoned or if
you're like me a day
you hear that plane that's my ride
oops gotta go the Ralph Jets here at the
garmi gets here and they're picking him
up they're gonna drop a rope ladder it's
very thrilling to watch but you don't
wanna you don't want to see that thanks
for hanging out with us
ladies gentlemen like looking that we
still got light we were worried about
losing the light and [ __ ] like that but
it's time to say goodbye yes I was
thinking like do we yeah my balls are
cold there you go I should have worn
underwear I was waiting for you to what
I should have worn underwear you're not
where are you commander usually I'm a
commando guy at all times
most times yes you should don't rub on
your zipper know what rich man non
zippers on the inside got lace and [ __ ]
yeah would you please sew some lace into
my zipper so my dick won't chafe or a
fuse to underpin I need a glans
protector no that velvet all velvet
inside my pants is the best piece of
advice you could walk away from this
with this show ladies gentlemen protect
your glands and your hands fun than the
other that's right when you wash your
hands sing happy birthday twice when you
want your glands sing whatever you need
to clean it got a davido then when you
bust a nut you're done then wash your
hands for two happy birthdays
I can't thank you enough for being here
man but there is no show without the guy
who normally sits my left foot for some
reason sitting to my right mr. Ralph
Fogg a garment ladies and gentlemen
let's hear it for my babble brother mr.
Kevin Smith and give it up for the ghost
The Invisible Man
who's been with us the whole time right
here man the six feet apart guy and
that's Hollywood babble-on for this week
I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman babble
the [ __ ] off good night from Hollywood